what can I tell myself
when I'm afraid my kids will do some of
the stuff I did
that Xanax is available
I mean how we made it why did we make it
we made terrible decisions they're the
kids they're gonna be all right because
they have our they can borrow some of
our knowledge they're gonna buy their
own and I mean I have we we have open
conversations about life and I'm trying
to walk that line of like I want you to
have a childhood I want to preserve some
of your innocence but I also know that
you need to be prepared for the world
that we live in and not to be a Debbie
Downer but these kids are having active
shooter drills in school like this is
the world we live in they need to be
prepared
so we go to Disneyland we eat ice cream
and we we talk about our feelings